[Música]
y llegamos directo a reino unido porque
listo si resiste nada que comienza que
entonces ya delinear sus políticas de
cara a la campaña interna para suceder
al primer ministro en funciones de boris
johnson luego de renunciar recordemos
por todos estos escándalos el más
conocido como el pari gate esto durante
la pandemia de kobe de 19 con estamos
por supuesto con nuestra corresponsal a
luisa pulido luisa la saludo muy buena
tarde pues ya finalmente conocemos a
estos dos últimos candidatos crisis una
aquí y lisette atrás luisa vamos a poner
entonces un poco en contexto de cómo han
sido estas votaciones que realmente han
sido bastante rápidas también se puede
se barajaba digamos la posibilidad de
pen y more than que también decía que
tenía pues de mucha popularidad dentro
de estos 200.000 votantes del partido
conservador y que si ella se enfrentaba
digamos a un rígido una pues ella sería
ella ya salió entonces de ésta contienda
electoral porque dentro de los
parlamentarios que votaron el más
popular era rico hizo una aquí pues
entonces llegaron estos dos candidatos
finalmente listos y ricci ricci sunat
como también se está delineando entonces
estas políticas y éstas a base de lo que
ellos quieran hacer si llegan a ser el
primer ministro para suceder a boris
johnson
hola buenas tardes atender la crisis que
vive la economía la crisis en el costo
de vida será la prioridad más grande del
nuevo primer ministro y es que la
inflación en este país está disparada
ayer se reveló la cifra que supera
nuevamente el 9% 9.4 esto impulsado
especialmente por el precio de los
alimentos y de la luz de la energía por
ello la importancia justamente sobre
esto ha girado la campaña y es aquí
donde se ven las grandes diferencias
entre risas unac y listas sobre el
manejo de la política fiscal del país
mientras listas que es la actual
secretaria de exteriores del país ha
prometido bajar los impuestos porque por
ejemplo el impuesto que se paga sobre el
salario aquí en el reino unido- que
subió desde abril ella ha prometido que
lo va a bajar inmediatamente y otros
pero richie zona que fue ministro de
finanzas hasta hasta hace tres semanas
cuando empezó todo este terremoto
político ha dicho no
o lo bajaré los impuestos hasta que la
inflación esté controlada y es que rich
es una que se describe a sí mismo como
el heredero de las políticas de margaret
thatcher esa primera ministra tan
popular e impopular conocida como la
dama de hierro que reformó este país en
los años 80 a richi sunat ha dicho en
una columna en el diario conservador the
telegraph que está listo para hacer
todas las reformas que sean necesarias
para darle un impulso una inyección a la
economía británica apaleada por supuesto
por varios factores globales pero
también por asuntos internos richie zona
que si es elegido se convertiría en el
primer primer ministro de origen indio
él nació aquí en inglaterra pero sus
padres llegaron de la india ha sido
diputado desde el año 2015 tiene
experiencia en varios gobiernos y
esencialmente se ha ocupado de asuntos
económicos y también hace parte con su
esposa de la lista de las personas más
ricas de este país ahora listas se ha
vuelto muy reconocida muy famosa entre
las bases y en las filas tories porque
él ha tenido un desempeño muy exitoso
dicen aquí sobre la gestión británica en
la guerra y en ucrania listas ha sido
diputada desde el año 2010 también ha
ocupado diferentes cargos en diferentes
gobiernos tories desde david cameron fue
el liberaldemócrata en su juventud pero
hoy es casi que la garantía del sector
de la derecha en los tories voto en
contra del break sit y si es elegida
sería entonces la tercera mujer primera
ministra en la historia de este país y
por supuesto hay muchas más prioridades
pero digamos que la gran diferencia se
ve sobre los asuntos económicos estamos
hablando por ejemplo del protocolo de
irlanda del norte que ha sembrado una
nueva polémica entre londres y bruselas
después de que se firmó el preside entre
el reino unido y la unión europea esta
región británica permanece con
alineación jurídica diferente es decir
hace parte del mercado único y el
sistema aduanero de la unión europea lo
que dice el gobierno es que hacer una
impone envío de un producto desde
cualquier ciudad británica a esa zona
del país es casi que una exportación por
la cantidad de producto la cantidad de
requisitos seguro gracia que es exigido
en este momento así que el gobierno de
boris johnson y listas que es la
negociadora con bruselas del protocolo
han presentado una legislación especial
en el parlamento británico para
desconocerla este protocolo lo que por
supuesto ha sembrado y ha iniciado una
nueva batalla jurídica con bruselas y
creo que estoy hablando mucho pero hay
muchos asuntos raúl por supuesto
muchísimo más de un 2 empezar a atender
el primer ministro así es así es luisa
le quiero preguntar antes de despedir
nuestro enlace de cómo será digamos la
carrera de ahora en adelante por downing
street- que se espera en esta campaña
que van a hacer no creo que también es
son debates televisivos en los que
podemos esperar y un montón de cosas
pero por favor resumen usted que es la
que mejor sabe
son seis semanas frenéticas habrá dos
debates el primero el próximo lunes de
la bbc el segundo de skynews el 4 de
agosto habrá 12 mitin en diferentes
ciudades de inglaterra en escocia gales
e irlanda del norte en la última reunión
de los candidatos será el 31 de agosto
aquí en londres eso les dará la
oportunidad a las bases conservadoras
unas 200.000 personas que serán las
responsables de elegir al nuevo primer
ministro la nueva primera ministra de
escuchar las propuestas tendrán estas
bases hasta el 2 de septiembre para
votar por su favorito el candidato
ganador el nuevo primer ministro y jefe
del partido conservador se revelará el 5
de septiembre y el 6 de septiembre
asumirá funciones visitar a la reina
isabel y entonces finalizará una nueva
etapa un nuevo gobierno conservador y
ese 6 de septiembre también será el
último día de boris johnson como primer
ministro británico louis antes de
pedirla le quiero preguntar vemos en
londres en nuevamente en un lado luego
que se registrara este récord de
temperaturas punto 3
grados o no luisa cómo está la
temperatura que dice y qué dicen las
autoridades digamos climáticas de aquí
en adelante
bueno todavía estamos en verano pero
como ustedes saben el verano no es tan
fuerte en el reino unido como en otros
países del mediterráneo todavía hace
calor pero después de esta alerta que
causó por supuesto estas altísimas
temperaturas esa misma noche empezaron a
bajar las temperaturas con tormentas
eléctricas y también inició de inmediato
una alerta de la agencia meteorológica
justamente por eso por por la por los
drásticos que iba a cambiar el clima
había que tener entonces cuidado con las
lluvias ha podido ha empezado a
descender poco a poco la temperatura
pero todavía raúl por fortuna estamos
disfrutando de buenas temperaturas pero
si hoy nuevamente el sol se ha escondido
esperamos volver a verlo pronto